the Joe Rogan experience leftover monkey
stuff yeah man it's the it's not it's
just still here
yeah so here and it's questions [ __ ] up
well we also needed it just a hundred
years ago
totally yeah yeah it was people were
doing duels when they were the president
was doing duels yeah you're right this
is so recent you're right yeah every
barrack [ __ ] man shoot each other with
little mini muskets in the [ __ ]
Street front everybody and you were the
president that's true was their
president that gotten a dual this is
true right I think you're right looked
it up as Andrew Jackson gotten like over
a hundred doors I think but that's like
was like that dual type to it was really
just like a challenge to see who if
you'd show up really and then like like
someone died shoot anybody he did like
one person Oh about it they don't aim at
each other that's why that's so I heard
that there's like you kind of like a
mere them doing something like that yeah
and that was a way to concede in one
duel he got shot I think in the chest
but he was such a badass he stayed he
like put his hand over it and held it
and insta cuz his gun jammed when he was
supposed to fire so the other guy got
him and then he fixed his gun shot the
guy in the head and that guy ended up
I'm pretty sure that's that's yeah but
like the one guy who killed town she do
you have a real motivation to kill a guy
when cheats in the chest
that's your leo eliminate threat now
this becomes really just has to stand
there he can't run away roof is that you
have to stand there and let it do shoot
you that's part of the deal right I
don't
yes a guy named Charles Dickinson not
the rider but a horse a rival horse
breeder and here's the account of there
oh my god okay it goes on May 30th 1806
Jackson and Dickinson met at Harrison's
Mills on the Red River in Logan Kentucky
at the first signal from there seconds
Dickinson fired Jackson received
Dickinson's first bullet in the chest
next to his heart Jackson put his hand
over the wound to staunch the flow of
blood and stayed standing long enough to
fire his gun Dickinson seconds claimed
that Jackson's first shot misfired
which would have meant that the wool was
over but in a breach of etiquette
Jackson reeked acht the gun and shot
again this time killing his opponent
although Jackson recovered he suffered
chronic pain from the wound for the
remainder of his life
Daniel Jackson was not prosecuted for
murder and the duel had very little
effect on a successful campaign for the
presidency in 1829 many American men in
the early 1800s particularly in the
south viewed dueling as a time-honored
tradition that was just a couple of
years ago with barbarians you're like
well sometimes you just got to do it
that is a time-honored tradition two
hundred years ago people were so goddamn
crazy that you could shoot someone in
the [ __ ] face in a duel a street
fight and then run for president and win
ya its consent consensual I mean there
are versions of that now but amazing but
yeah his divorce rate raised more of a
scandal than him killing that guy Wow
how's that possible Wow I mean again
priorities different societies yeah what
is gossip like back then like gossip
magazines and have like like hand
printed newspaper with gossip in it that
they would hand out yeah well why would
his divorce become a big deal did the
printing press back then right oh yeah
for sure yeah you know the United States
got it theirs in 1850 like everyone had
to buy into it people are so goofy just
a couple hundred years ago they were so
goofy I mean that's one of the best
examples of like a difference in a shift
in culture imagine hearing that today
imagine hearing that we had slid so far
down that Trump and Putin were engaging
in a duel and they were gonna go back to
back and chop cheated and shot him and
we're yeah I wonder who would cheat who
will have that happen if Trump took a
bullet but his gun misfired then here
eek arced it and fire again oh that
would be something that's what but
that's what he did that's what Jackson
did oh my god Jackson yeah yeah though
okay so he married Rachel Jackson who
this is part of the duel because the guy
killed Dickinson had publicly called her
a bigamist because she married Jackson
not knowing her first husband had fought
not finalized the divorce or something
like that so that was a bigger scandal
that he was married to some
already married woman Oh like that got
outed so he's like [ __ ] you wanna
kill you oh my goodness Wow
so he challenged him to a duel because
Jackson challenged him to a duel yeah
that and I renig horse bet he said oh my
god of course you can't cheat on horse
betting
yeah that's those are two big things man
don't say a man's wife is a bigamist
don't say that's what they're shooting
people over [ __ ] horse bets at [ __ ]
yeah those are barbarian people in this
our ancestors just two hundred years ago
this is like very civil civil
barbarianism Oh barbarians yeah like
we're barbarians with their rules
[Applause]